are you there for pete when people are
on him when kanye's involved in killing
it i got thrown in that too oddly enough
but
at the end of the day man we're
we're young men trying to find our place
in the world and figuring it out and it
doesn't really help when you got a
million voices you know
ripping you apart
after getting roped into the drama
himself machine gun kelly is weighing in
on how his pal pete davidson is holding
up amid all those attacks from kanye
west we're all just figuring it out man
this is life
yeah well for pete davidson life has
been pretty different since he started
dating kanye's estranged wife kim
kardashian the two first linked up when
she hosted saturday night live in the
fall now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
fast forward to 2022 and kanye started
coming for kim's new boo in his new
music
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
too
and through a series of social media
strikes
now he's texting me talking and bragging
about how he's in bed with my wife
enter machine gun kelly whose name kaye
invoked in a sense deleted diatribe on
instagram
after slamming pete and weirdly the walt
disney company kaye wrote quote no one's
ever heard a machine gun kelly song
mgk's music has actually been topping
the charts for years and he's a big
enough star to land an invite to the
howard stern show so i was blessed
that's where the rocker opened up about
pete and how he's been there for his pal
during this media storm and we love
everybody man we have so much love
you know we it's it's it's almost like
if we need to be the vessels for
people's anger then you know so be it
that must be why we're here mgk says all
pete wants to do is keep things positive
and is hoping for the best moving
forward i do hope that
they can feel our spirit and see that
you know
that we love you though and that love
runs deep especially when it comes to
mgk's bromance with the snl star hated
the most so i keep my haters close let
them know i want to smoke so much bread
i gotta boast this burner turn you into
toast
up next their biggest collaboration yet
at mgk's upcoming wedding to fiance
megan fox will pete davidson be your
best man i believe he will be i think my
side is gonna is gonna be
um an art is gonna be an army a few i
have i have so many
close and best friends that have been
with me for all these years but yeah i
think pete's absolutely gonna
be standing there with me and we we
should just mic him just for commentary
anyway it's kind of cool man and get
this
mgk told howard that the power couples
have even double dated
you know we rented out a theater league
megan kevin if he went to see a movie
now even that sounds like great hijinks
you and pete rent a a theater for your
women so you guys can see the movie on
your own so while we know mgk and megan
are eternal twin flames he's the most
talented boy in the world we'll stay
tuned to see if kim and pete are in game
two
at the end of the day life is about
being happy
what we do know is peta is going to have
a piece of kim for life
no literally because he got her name
branded on his chest when you say
branding so like literally like an iron
thing yes went on to his body yes to
brand kim yes uh-huh
i don't know like i
i just think he was like i want
something that's there that i can't you
know get rid of my tattoos because he's
in the process of getting rid of his arm
tats
and his neck hats so he's like i don't
want to be able to get rid of it or to
cover it up and i just wanted it like
there as like a scar
on me